[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti
e se posso chiedere l'immagine alla
regia così iniziamo da lì tanto volevo
dire che sento molto il peso il valore
di questo invito in questa terra che ho
iniziato a conoscere bene da qualche
anno da quando appunto abbiamo avviato
quel progetto a cui si alludeva poco fa
cioè quel festival che si intitola cum
insieme a massimo recalcati che lo
dirige
diciamola il coordinamento scientifico
del sottoscritto è un festival ma com è
una parola molto bella in aramaico
significa alzati quindi siamo già
diciamo in tema se il nostro tema è re
start
ricominciamo è la parola che cristo
rivolge alla fanciulla che ha risanato
appunto invitandola ad alzarsi e questa
parola ha un sottotitolo nel nostro
festival che è curare educare governare
sono tre parole che nominano quelli che
freud
in uno scritto diciamo della sua
vecchiaia scritta quasi un valore di
testamento denuncia come mestiere
impossibili
la cura il governo l'educazione sono dei
mestieri di impossibile perché dice così
io penso si possa dire molto
semplicemente perché tutte e tre questi
mestieri sono dei mestieri che hanno a
che fare con il passaggio della
possibilità dell'inizio con la
trasmissione da una generazione
all'altra da un soggetto all'altro della
possibilità di un inizio cioè di un
nuovo inizio di una nuova chance questo
punto il nostro tema
intanto è comparsa l'immagine io ve ne
dirò qualcosa verso la fine del mio
discorso ma intanto vi invito a guardare
dove non verrebbe fatto di guardare cioè
la parte bassa diciamo dell'immagine c'è
della gente che sonnecchia questa gente
che sonnecchia importante forse la cosa
fondamentale di questa
di questa immagine di questa costruzione
che qualcuno ha detto essere la più
bella pittura del mondo e la figura
forse più interessante è questa no è
quella che più chiaramente si vede
essere immerso nel sonno è l'autore di
questo affresco che sta sansepolcro si
chiamava piero della francesca
allora dicevo tremestieri impossibili
perché tutti e tre hanno a che fare con
la trasmissione della possibilità di un
inizio di un nuovo inizio
ma il punto è capire bene il senso
dell'impossibile il senso di questo
impossibile che freud sul limitare della
sua vita sul finire del suo tempo indica
come il carattere chiave di queste tre
professioni una delle quali è la sua
evidentemente quella della cura cosa
vuol dire impossibile io penso si
debbano evitare due rischi simmetrici di
pensare che sono professioni impossibili
che trasmettere la possibilità di un
nuovo inizio è possibile solo nel senso
che è molto difficile e molto difficile
ma poi dopo tutto alla fin fine è
possibile non è questo quello che lui
intende dire
e poi bisogna evitare anche l'alta via
l'altra semplificazione io penso di dire
sono professioni impossibili cioè
neanche questo è ciò che freud intende
neanche questo è il modo in cui noi
dobbiamo intendere la difficoltà del
nuovo inizio è una impossibilità si
tratta di pensare l'impossibile a
cavallo tra queste due possibilità o in
un punto intermedio ed è su questo che
l'immagine ci aiuterà poi a un certo
punto del nostro ragionamento allora
come pensare a questo punto intermedio
come pensare questa impossibilità in un
modo fecondo
ecco io qui farei un secondo passo un
riferimento non più alla psicoanalisi ma
la filosofia questa volta non più a
freud ma a un autore fondamentale io
credo per il nostro tempo anche se
lontano nel tempo e coevo di berson ma
il coevo di freud cioè verso persone un
grande pensatore dell'inizio del
novecento
ha scritto un testo meraviglioso
brevissimo si intitola il possibile e
reale e che è un manifesto della
filosofia a venir è un manifesto del
nostro tempo e del tempo che verrà in
qualche misura e che cosa dice persone
in questo testo quando ragiona appunto
sul nesso tra il possibile e reale dice
una cosa molto chiara molto netta anche
se è difficile da pensare poi in tutte
le sue implicazioni cioè non si tratta
di pensare l'inizio il nuovo inizio la
nuova chance come la traduzione di un
possibile in un atto di una possibilità
in una realizzazione di una possibilità
in un'attualità non è così che si deve
pensare si deve piuttosto pensare dice
persone questo è all'orizzonte questo
veramente è una proposizione da veggente
che lui pronuncia un certo punto in
questo testo perché molta biologia
contemporanea molta fisica contemporanea
molta matematica contemporanea lavorano
esattamente su questo punto bisogna
pensare non che l'evento presente
l'inizio attualizzi una potenzialità
data perché se pensiamo così nulla
accadrà mai nessun nuovo inizio nessun
re start nessuna trasmissione della
possibilità di questo ricominciamento
bisogna pensare in tutt'altro modo
bisogna pensare dice berson che è
l'evento presente che disegna nel suo
intorno estrae dalla sua circostanza ciò
che verrà poi come il prima perdonate la
strategia di questa formula clio nella
sua generalità poi doveva darle un
contenuto usando l'immagine di piero
della francesca
ma intanto vela ripeto della tratteggio
nuovamente bisogna immaginare che ogni
evento presente ogni nostro gesto
quotidiano ogni atto di un qualsiasi
sistema nella misura in cui è auto
organizzato e auto organizzanti si
produce diciamo così le sue condizioni
di possibilità non realizzano le esegue
viverlo nell'esecuzione di un programma
nessun organismo vivente esegue il suo
dna
nessuno dei nostri atti realizza dei
possibili che erano già dati ma ogni
sistema ogni gesto ogni vita produce il
suo campo di possibilità produce come
dire dopo ciò che apparirà come prima
produce il suo passato questo è il
paradosso gigantesco davanti a cui
berson e ripeto tutta la biologia
contemporanea tutta la fisica
contemporanea si confrontano l'evento
presente produce il suo passato la sua
condizione di possibilità alle sue
circostanze ciò che sembra dopo averlo
reso possibile e per questo che ogni
evento realizza qui e ora di impossibile
ogni ricominciamento sembra del tutto
impossibile invece realizza ciò che
sembrava completamente fuori dalla
calcolabilità allora per dare un
contenuto in qualche misura più concreto
più vicino a noi
dotato di una qualche possibilità di
frequentazione al di fuori della
difficoltà della teoria della filosofia
delle piste mo logie ho pensato ho
pensato di usare l'immagine che chiede
di mettere di nuovo nello sfondo
l'immagine di piero della francesca
questa è una è un affresco che diciamo
realizza un paradosso nel paradosso
davanti a cui qualunque pittore come
piero cioè qualunque pittore cristiano
si trova confrontato cioè rappresentare
qualcosa che nessuno ha mai visto
qualcosa di cui non esiste una
descrizione qualcosa di cui siamo i
testi canonici non parlano per un motivo
molto serio cioè che nessuno sguardo
umano può aver visto un evento
soprannaturale allora voi immaginate di
dover dipinge essendo un pittore
cristiano vicino alla fede vicino ai
canoni che regolano la pittura del suo
tempo di dover rappresentare questo
paradosso un evento inimmaginabile dover
dare immagine a un evento inimmaginabile
dover dare consistenza a qualcosa che
nessuna legge diciamo umana e naturale
consente permette giustifica come
dipingere l'impossibile di un nuovo
inizio appunto cristo che risorge il
paradigma stesso dell'evento per tutta
la nostra tradizione diciamo così
e allora il colpo di genio mettiamoci
della gente che dorme
mettiamoci della gente che sonnecchia
alla base e che sostiene per dire così
l'evento macroscopico l'evento grandioso
no vedete la figura del cristo che
troneggia con questa postura statuaria
con questa ho tratto monumentale in
qualche modo per all'essenziale si gioca
tutto sotto si gioca nel luogo di questo
sonno
allora come intendere questo sonno io
credo che qui ci sia un insegnamento
figurale diciamo così nel quale
traducono in modo molto concreto tutto
quello che vi ho detto sin qui usando
gli strumenti più freddi probabilmente
più astratti della teoria che cosa vuol
dire che sonnecchiano questi militi che
dovevano stare a guardia del sepolcro e
che invece si sono addormentati e non
vedono nulla
io direi che rappresentano diciamo così
il luogo dell'inizio nella misura in cui
l'inizio il nuovo inizio in quanto
impossibile in quanto non sta alle
condizioni date in un campo avviene
fuori campo
l'inizio che cos'è si potrebbe dire è
l'evento in quanto accade ricalcolando
le sue condizioni di possibilità e
cedendole essendo di un'altra ordine
diciamo così e dunque per esempio
eccedendo l'ordine della coscienza del
sapere della calcolabilità il possibile
essenzialmente un algoritmo è un calcolo
si dà a vedere dopo e nella assenza
diciamo così è nell'assenza di coscienza
nell'assenza di sapere nell'assenza di
calcolo che il nuovo inizio si produce
allora noi che cosa facciamo
costantemente in ogni gesto della nostra
vita quotidiana
oppure detto in altri termini che cosa
fa un sistema vivente in ogni atto e in
ogni istante del suo essere in atto del
suo essere preso in un processo di auto
organizzazione
beh io direi lavora come un matto ogni
sistema ognuno di noi lavora come un
matto per produrre un campo di possibili
per dare vita per disegnare un campo di
possibili tale per cui fuori campo
in un'altra scena in una scena diciamo
così non visibile non vista in una scena
marginale in una scena che è affidata al
sonno alla dimensione della notte alla
dimensione dell'impeccabile perché in
questa seconda scena apparentemente meno
spettacolare apparentemente non decisiva
secondaria perché in questa altra scena
si produca alla grande trasformazione
la metamorfosi in altri termini ciò che
insegna
per un verso freud con la psicoanalisi
per un altro verso berson con la
filosofia per un'altra verso la biologia
la teoria della complessità
contemporanea e ciò che pieno della
francesca rappresenta perfettamente con
la sua immagine è che il grande evento
visibile della rinascita
re start certo che avviene nella parte
in luce avviene di giorno diciamo così
avviene dove tutti noi siamo portati a
guardare ma al suo fondo diciamo così al
fondo dell'immagine c'è la parte oscura
c'è il sonno e laddove noi non guardiamo
nel regno delle piccole differenze dei
piccoli eventi quotidiani dei minuscoli
atti con cui ogni organismo lotta per
affermare se stesso ea livello di queste
piccole minuscole differenze che si
produce la grande differenza
ecco la grande differenza si potrebbe
dire l'evento della rinascita
l'incalcolabile l'impossibile di ciò che
accade riconfigurando tutto il sistema è
semplicemente un nome di ciò che accade
nel campo anonimo nel campo della prosa
del mondo diciamo così nel campo
dell'illuminazione l'innominabile che
continuamente accade che continuamente
ridisegna e produce i possibili potrebbe
dire i possibili non sono ciò da cui
dipende ciò che noi facciamo ciò che noi
facciamo una specie di assoluto e
produce ciò da cui sembra dipendere le
condizioni di possibilità vengono
costantemente infante io credo che
questo sia un messaggio familiare
probabilmente a tutti voi che vivete in
una terra che è stata assegnata diciamo
dalla tragedia che è stata piegata dalla
perdita dal lutto dalla mancanza dal
peso dell'impossibile e che nonostante
questo ha mostrato diciamo così che il
possibile si genera costantemente che il
possibile un frutto dell'evento e non
ciò da cui l'evento dipende
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]